can you um
play my therapist for a second and if we
talk about creative destruction
i think not bukowski um
hunters thompson is a quote something
like
for all instances of beauty many souls
must be trampled
wow
[Laughter]
but it the there just needs to be an
aspect of competition
that destroys you were talking about
entrepreneurs
instead of on the outside of the circle
of order
striving to make sense to compress
volatility of the chaos of the of the
universe
is there some way to protect a little
bit
against the pain of that destruction of
that creative destruction
that uh entrepreneur screaming on fire
as he
enlightens the rest of us is there some
role for us humans together
in the togetherness of it
also government but any kind of
collectives in helping that entrepreneur
who's on fire to maybe
after a few minutes to uh spray him with
some water
and uh put him out of his misery
i would say that you know pain
is the inarguable basis of being
right pain is no matter how you try
to explain it away or
or describe it or
it's not something you can rationalize
away right it's no one
i think ever like someone may want to
cut themselves to have an endorphin high
but no one wants to suffer
would say right so pain in that sense it
is what we're constantly trying to deal
with
and to move away from or create buffers
between us and potential pain or
potential on you know uncertainty
and that pain is information
when we experience something that is
misfit to the outcome we desired
that pain is what puts us it encourages
us to
change our trajectory to get back on
course towards our our valued aim
so as far as
you know you need entrepreneurs that are
exploring and you're trying to do
something new if you're a pioneer of any
kind
you are courageously facing pain you're
willfully
confronting it so i don't think it's
avoidable in that sense
it's not like we can have pain-free
economic growth like
the central bank would maybe uh have us
lend to believe that
we can just run these experiments and
when they fail we'll just paper over all
the losses and continue
or you're just delaying and exacerbating
the inevitable volatility back to
reality
but what i would say is that capitalism
because we're building
we're increasing the capital stock of
the world which again capital
is the mitigation of risk so we're
reducing the overall risk of existence
by accumulating more capital in the
world
and that's what protects that
entrepreneur that's deciding hey
i saved up a million bucks i'm gonna go
try this business idea
i'm gonna put all my my money on the
line and if he goes up in flames
then he his cost of living when he comes
back to reality and he's starting over
from zero his cost of living is
substantially lower
starting over from zero then he would be
out in the wilderness on his own
right so it's the the accumulation of
capital stock
is the buffer against uncertainty for
everyone
and it gives you actually more potential
to go out and experiment to go out and
confront
the chaos of nature because you are
better healed
effectively
you